hey guys welcome to gamescom 2015 I'm
Dave here the soldier himself rob
crossley you've been boots on the ground
some call of duty today that's right yes
I've been playing a single player and
multiplayer playing all things I know
right tell me about you played single
player post single player so I've got
confess I'm very cool of GT since 10 / 3
there's been a wild yeah Staind some
great so having a while since I last
played a call you GT game I had a bit of
time off I'm so actually going back to
it I was kind of please yeah everything
yeah I mean they've nailed the baseline
gameplay it's so polished now it's so it
works so thoroughly now but there's a
couple of additions the big thing
they're pushing on this time is full
player co-op in the campaign the entire
campaign for violence the entire
template campaign can be four player
co-op or three player 2 player with a
single player so it's kind of changed
how they build the levels like with
previous Call of Duty's it's kind of
like you just go through a tunnel don't
you get funneled yeah i can i'm thinking
of like classic call of duty levels and
thinking that would no way fit your
players sort of their expanded the play
space they have done yeah so it's big
open battle scenes now basically and
you're fighting against robots so I mean
one is some some sort of robots other
humans
tiny max hello tiny max yeah okay
offenders but you also have your own
sort of powers now as well he's really
cool like augmentation Howard I don't
like to get all the s expert in hands
excellent yes is good there's if you
press the left on the d-pad like you get
like a almost like a visor mode now so
it will tell you how far away enemies
are in turn that I've like a radar on
them so many a vision terminator vision
yet or summer semester prying you can
just see really cool stuff and if you
love the grenade you'll see the art of
the grenades I could have done with that
when I used to play around in school
because oh my goodness that would don't
help so what we have so much I've been
again why we in school you have the
technology huge if I you had the
technology / probably just destroy
everything so I the relevant Rosie we
got so okay baby with down on the d-pad
it is like a spin wheel comes up okay
I'm choose between like I think it's
five or six or seven powers one of which
is like you can sort of manipulate
robots you can sort of turn them on each
other okay singing just goes at the
robot or just go again went over 3100
coming time okay so you can manipulate
soldier on so I robot on to another one
okay but the other one that was really
cool ways you can making go kamikaze on
each other so this one rue it was like
oh not again tomorrow hello shoot me and
I am it elated him and he just ran
towards mix soldier and rugby tackle
them and they both died and i love like
and when you think about like cooler
duties of real serious games like it's
that point everything's going up get to
that point everything's blowing up to
that point of it as well as actually
since the the previous titles kind of
we're like pretty broody like remember
one or fair to there's the whole like
nuclear seasons yeah a black ops is
quite bar yeah espionage kind of stuff
yeah it sounds like there they've
realized that ok we are the alch a
shooter let's have some fun with this
let's have a little bit of fun let's hop
robots Robbie technique
British blue oh I played a little bit of
multiple air like I am so [ __ ] that
multiplayer so it was like you know I'm
kill bill where kiddo is trained with
pie made yeah and he just beats her up
yeah it was like that for me you would
be in the Bible as I was I was kid I in
this scenario yes sorry it wasn't your
wedding then Ice enemy one of my enemies
took on this drone and he was just
showering shelling the [ __ ] out of me
basically every time i respawned he
would just destroy me listen german kid
behind me that was doing he was laughing
a pair of laughing I was like this is
not fun run chronically laughed at by a
german kid so your time is it was awful
really i just got brutalized but that's
not to say more player was a fun it was
just this kid just had it in for me and
he just wanted to destroy me so i got
one more thing to ask you I've not
played call of duty in a while I was
saying you I always kind of those too
much it was that every year so I kind of
took a break from like you do you think
that this one will be the one to get
people who like you and I've not played
them in a while to get back into the
series no no I think it will be for
people that like the series I think it
will be a fun new iteration but I think
they feel that are using interest in
Call of Duty I think something
differently to happen I think something
very interesting these that to happen to
get them back into it they're still
iterating on old ideas and these are
still reading interesting iterations
really interesting ideas are ending to
it but something more drastic I think
needs to be done to get people back
awesome well now they're on a three-year
dev psychol with more teams work and
hopefully they can cook up some really
new ideas and we're guessing fresh but
Rob for your call of duty news I'm for
everything from gamescom 2015 make sure
you stay tuned to gamespot
you